Les contaré una historia de hace 200 años.
En 1820 el astrónomo francés Alexis Bouvard casi se convirtió
en la segunda persona en la historia humana en descubrir un planeta.
Había estado siguiendo la posición de Urano por el cielo nocturno
usando viejos catálogos de estrellas,
y no dio la vuelta al Sol
de la forma en que sus predicciones decían que debería.
A veces iba demasiado rápido
a veces un poco lento.
Bouvard sabía que sus predicciones eran perfectas.
Así que debían ser esos viejos catálogos de estrellas que eran malos.
Les dijo a los astrónomos del momento:
"Hagan mejores mediciones".
Entonces las hicieron.
Los astrónomos pasaron las siguientes dos décadas
rastreando meticulosamente la posición de Urano en el cielo,
pero todavía no se ajustaba a las predicciones de Bouvard.
Para 1840, se había vuelto obvio.
El problema no eran esos viejos catálogos de estrellas,
el problema eran las predicciones.
Y los astrónomos sabían por qué.
Se dieron cuenta de que debía haber un planeta gigante y distante.
justo más allá de la órbita de Urano
que tiraba de esa órbita
a veces tirando un poco más rápido
a veces reteniéndolo.
Debe haber sido frustrante en 1840
ver estos efectos gravitacionales de este planeta distante y gigante,
pero aún no saber cómo encontrarlo realmente.
Créanme, es realmente frustrante.
(Risas)
Pero en 1846, otro astrónomo francés,
Urbain Le Verrier,
a través de las matemáticas
descubrió cómo predecir la ubicación del planeta.
Envió su predicción al observatorio de Berlín,
abrieron su telescopio
y en la primera noche encontraron este tenue punto de luz
moviéndose lentamente por el cielo
y descubrieron Neptuno.
Estaba en el cielo muy cerca de la ubicación prevista de Le Verrier.
La historia de la predicción y la discrepancia y la nueva teoría
y los descubrimientos triunfantes son muy clásicos
y Le Verrier se hizo tan famoso por eso,
que la gente trató de entrar en el acto de inmediato.
En los últimos 163 años,
docenas de astrónomos han usado algún tipo de supuesta discrepancia orbital
para predecir la existencia de algún nuevo planeta en el sistema solar.
Siempre se han equivocado.
La más famosa de estas predicciones erróneas.
vino de Percival Lowell,
que estaba convencido de que debía haber un planeta más allá de Urano y Neptuno,
jugando con esas órbitas.
Y así, cuando se descubrió Plutón en 1930
en el Observatorio Lowell,
todos asumieron que debía ser el planeta que Lowell había predicho.
Estaban equivocados.
Urano y Neptuno están exactamente donde se supone que deben estar.
Llevó 100 años,
pero Bouvard finalmente tuvo razón.
Los astrónomos debían hacer mejores mediciones.
Y cuando las hicieron,
esas mejores medidas dieron como resultado que
no hay planeta más allá de la órbita de Urano y Neptuno
y Plutón es miles de veces muy pequeño
para tener algún efecto en esas órbitas en absoluto.
Y, aunque Plutón resultó no ser el planeta
que se pensaba que era originalmente
fue el primer descubrimiento de lo que ahora se sabe que son
miles de pequeños objetos helados en órbita más allá de los planetas.
Aquí se pueden ver las órbitas de Júpiter,
Saturno, Urano y Neptuno,
y en ese pequeño círculo en el centro está la Tierra
y el Sol y casi todo lo que saben y aman.
Y esos círculos amarillos en el borde
son esos cuerpos helados más allá de los planetas.
Esos cuerpos helados son empujados y tirados
por los campos gravitacionales de los planetas
de maneras completamente predecibles.
Todo gira alrededor del Sol exactamente como se supone que debe hacerlo.
Casi.
Entonces, en 2003,
se descubrí lo que había en ese momento,
el objeto más distante conocido en todo el sistema solar.
Es difícil no mirar ese cuerpo solitario allá afuera
y decir, oh sí, claro, entonces Lowell estaba equivocado,
no había planetas más allá de Neptuno,
Pero esto, esto podría ser un nuevo planeta.
La verdadera pregunta era:
¿qué tipo de órbita tiene alrededor del Sol?
¿Va en un círculo alrededor del Sol
como lo hace un planeta?
¿O es solo un miembro típico de este cinturón helado de cuerpos
que se salió un poco hacia afuera y ahora está de regreso?
Esta es precisamente la pregunta.
Los astrónomos intentaban responder sobre Urano hace 200 años.
Lo hicieron usando observaciones pasadas por alto de Urano
desde hace 91 años antes de su descubrimiento
para descubrir toda su órbita.
No podríamos ir tan lejos,
pero encontramos observaciones de nuestro objeto de 13 años antes
eso nos permitió descubrir cómo fue alrededor del Sol.
Entonces la pregunta es,
¿está en una órbita circular alrededor del Sol, como un planeta,
o está de regreso,
como uno de estos cuerpos helados típicos?
Y la respuesta es
no.
Tiene una órbita masivamente alargada
que toma 10 000 años para dar la vuelta al Sol.
Llamamos a este objeto Sedna
por la diosa inuit del mar,
en honor a los lugares fríos y helados donde pasa todo su tiempo.
Ahora sabemos que Sedna,
es aproximadamente un tercio del tamaño de Plutón
y es un miembro relativamente típico
de esos cuerpos helados más allá de Neptuno.
Relativamente típico, excepto por esta extraña órbita.
Podrían mirar esta órbita y decir:
"Sí, eso es extraño, 10 000 años para dar la vuelta al Sol",
pero esa no es realmente la parte extraña.
Lo extraño es que, en esos 10 000 años,
Sedna nunca se acerca a nada más en el sistema solar.
Incluso en su aproximación más cercana al Sol,
Sedna está más lejos de Neptuno
que Neptuno de la Tierra.
Si Sedna hubiera tenido una órbita como esta,
que besa la órbita de Neptuno una vez alrededor del Sol,
habría sido realmente fácil de explicar.
Habría sido solo un objeto
que había estado en una órbita circular alrededor del Sol
en esa región de cuerpos helados,
que se había acercado demasiado a Neptuno una vez,
y luego salió la honda y ahora está de regreso.
Pero Sedna nunca se acerca a nada conocido en el sistema solar
que pudiera haberle dado ese tirón.
Neptuno no puede ser responsable,
Pero algo tenía que ser responsable.
Esta fue la primera vez desde 1845
que vimos los efectos gravitacionales de algo en el sistema solar exterior
y no se sabía lo que era.
En realidad, pensé que sabía cuál era la respuesta.
Claro, podría haber sido un planeta distante y gigante
en el sistema solar exterior,
pero para entonces, esa idea era tan ridícula
y había sido tan desacreditada
que no me la tomé muy en serio.
Pero hace 4500 millones de años,
cuando el Sol se formó en un capullo de cientos de otras estrellas,
cualquiera de esas estrellas
podría haberse acercado demasiado a Sedna
perturbándolo en la órbita que tiene hoy.
Cuando ese grupo de estrellas se disipó en la galaxia,
la órbita de Sedna habría quedado como un registro fósil
de esta historia más temprana del Sol.
Estaba tan emocionado con esta idea,
con la idea de que podríamos mirar
en la historia fósil del nacimiento del Sol,
que pasé la siguiente década
buscando más objetos con órbitas como Sedna.
En ese período de diez años, encontré cero.
(Risas)
Pero mis colegas, Chad Trujillo y Scott Sheppard, hicieron un mejor trabajo,
y ahora han encontrado varios objetos con órbitas como Sedna,
Lo cual es superemocionante.
Pero lo que es aún más interesante.
es que descubrieron que todos estos objetos
no solo están en estas órbitas distantes y alargadas,
sino también comparten un valor común de este oscuro parámetro orbital
que en mecánica celeste llamamos argumento del perihelio.
Cuando se dieron cuenta de que estaba agrupado en un argumento de perihelio,
inmediatamente saltaron arriba y abajo,
diciendo que debe ser causado por un planeta distante y gigante allá afuera,
lo que es muy emocionante, pero no tiene ningún sentido.
Intentaré explicarles el porqué con una analogía.
Imaginen a una persona caminando por una plaza
y mirando 45 grados a su lado derecho.
Hay muchas razones que pueda suceder,
Es muy fácil de explicar, no es gran cosa.
Imaginen ahora a muchas personas diferentes,
todos caminando en diferentes direcciones a través de la plaza,
pero todos miran 45 grados en la dirección en que se mueven.
Todos se mueven en diferentes direcciones,
todos miran en diferentes direcciones,
pero todos miran 45 grados hacia la dirección del movimiento.
¿Qué podría causar algo así?
No tengo idea.
Es muy difícil pensar en alguna razón para que eso suceda.
(Risas)
Y esto es esencialmente lo que esa agrupación
en argumento de perihelio nos estaba diciendo.
Los científicos estaban desconcertados y asumieron que debía ser una casualidad
y algunas malas observaciones.
Dijeron a los astrónomos:
"Hagan mejores mediciones".
Sin embargo, realmente eché un vistazo muy cuidadoso a esas medidas,
y tenían razón
Estos objetos realmente todos compartían
un valor común del argumento del perihelio,
y no debería ser así.
Algo tenía que estar causando eso.
La pieza final del rompecabezas entró en su lugar en 2016,
cuando mi colega Konstantin Batygin,
quien trabaja tres puertas más abajo de mí, y yo
nos dimos cuenta de que la razón por la que todos estaban desconcertados
era porque el argumento del perihelio era solo una parte de la historia.
Si se observa estos objetos de la manera correcta,
todos están alineados en el espacio en la misma dirección,
y todos están inclinados en el espacio en la misma dirección.
Es como si todas esas personas en la plaza estuvieran caminando en la misma dirección
y todos miran 45 grados hacia el lado derecho.
Eso es fácil de explicar.
Todos están mirando algo.
Estos objetos en el sistema solar exterior están reaccionando a algo.
¿Pero qué?
Konstantin y yo pasamos un año
tratando de encontrar alguna explicación que no fuera un planeta distante y gigante
en el sistema solar exterior.
No queríamos ser las personas 33 y 34 en la historia en proponer este planeta
y que una vez más que nos dijeran que estábamos equivocados.
Pero después de un año,
realmente no había elección.
No podríamos encontrar otra explicación
aparte de que hay un lejano
planeta masivo en una órbita alargada,
inclinado con respecto al resto del sistema solar,
que está forzando estos patrones para estos objetos
en el sistema solar exterior.
Adivinen qué más hace un planeta como este.
Recuerden esa extraña órbita de Sedna,
¿Cómo se alejó del Sol en una dirección?
Un planeta como este haría órbitas así todo el día.
Sabíamos que estábamos en algo.
Entonces esto nos lleva a hoy.
Básicamente estamos en el 1845, París.
(Risas)
Vemos los efectos gravitacionales de un planeta gigante distante,
y estamos intentando elaborar los cálculos
para decirnos dónde mirar, para apuntar nuestros telescopios,
para encontrar este planeta
Hemos realizado enormes series de simulaciones por computadora,
meses masivos de cálculos analíticos
y esto es lo que puedo decirles hasta ahora.
Primero, este planeta, lo llamamos Planeta Nueve,
porque eso es lo que es.
El Planeta Nueve es seis veces la masa de la Tierra.
No es un poco más pequeño que Plutón,
discutamos sobre si es un planeta o no.
Es el quinto planeta más grande de todo nuestro sistema solar.
Para el contexto, déjenme mostrarles los tamaños de los planetas.
En la parte de atrás, pueden ver los enormes Júpiter y Saturno.
Junto a ellos, un poco más pequeños, Urano y Neptuno.
Arriba en la esquina, planetas terrestres: Mercurio, Venus, Tierra y Marte.
Incluso pueden ver ese cinturón
de cuerpos helados más allá de Neptuno, del cual Plutón es miembro,
buena suerte descubriendo cuál es.
Y aquí está el Planeta Nueve.
El planeta nueve es grande.
Planeta Nueve es tan grande
que deberían preguntarse por qué no lo hemos encontrado todavía.
Bueno, el Planeta Nueve es grande,
pero también está muy, muy lejos.
Está algo así como 15 veces más lejos que Neptuno.
Y eso lo hace unas 50 000 veces más débil que Neptuno.
Y también, el cielo es un lugar realmente grande.
Nos hemos reducido a donde creemos que está,
a un área relativamente pequeña del cielo,
pero aún nos llevaría años
cubrir sistemáticamente el área del cielo
con los grandes telescopios que necesitamos
para ver algo que está tan lejos y tan débil.
Por suerte, podríamos no tener que hacerlo.
Al igual que Bouvard usó observaciones no reconocidas de Urano
de 91 años antes de su descubrimiento,
apuesto a que hay imágenes no reconocidas
que muestran la ubicación del Planeta Nueve.
Será una empresa computacional masiva
revisar todos los datos antiguos
y escoger ese débil planeta en movimiento.
Pero estamos en camino.
Y creo que nos estamos acercando.
Entonces yo diría, prepárense.
No vamos a igualar el de Le Verrier
"Haz una predicción,
encontrar el planeta en una sola noche
cerca de donde lo predijiste".
Pero apuesto a que en los próximos años
algún astrónomo en alguna parte
encontrará un tenue punto de luz,
moviéndose lentamente por el cielo
y anunciará triunfalmente el descubrimiento de un nuevo
y posiblemente no sea el último,
planeta real de nuestro sistema solar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)